let's talk about 2016 because they don't
talk about that enough on cable news do
they
you guys remember Ralph Nader he runs
for president every couple years screws
up the whole thing maybe Al Gore
wouldn't be a president he loves seat
belts especially in the 70s yeah we
could have had Algor perhaps who knows
so he came out with an interesting memo
outlining 20 people that he calls
moderately enlightened rich people merps
that he thinks could run for president
in 2016 and that might actually be
decent
okay so here's some of the people on
list you got have Oprah on any list of
rich people that are doing things we got
Bill Gates Ted Turner former third party
New York Governor candidate Tom Golisano
and former AOL chief executive Steve
Case and let's get we've got a quote of
Nader explaining why he thinks these
merps could lead us into the future
presently only very rich modestly
enlightened people could have a chance
to break this introverted cycle of
political oligarchy which unenlightened
rich people generally approve of that
sets its own rules makes its own laws
and appoints its own judges and even
brazenly forces tax payers to finance
its quadrennial political conventions
Ralph Nader should probably maybe use a
period and occasionally in a sentence to
explain something that would've been
easier for me could use a little more
makeup when he's on TV all right but
let's not make this about Nader it is
our only chance to break the system this
endless money machine system could it
possibly be true that a billionaire self
financing his campaign might actually be
the one chance we have to get money out
of politics as reverse as that sounds
well he wants to crack open the system
let somebody else in so that the same
people don't get elected and the same
corporations don't keep donating right
yeah so maybe having a third party
somebody like a I was gonna say Madonna
I met Oprah I mean honestly I would vote
for Bill Maher or Jon Stewart or even
somebody like Beyonce because other
dignitaries
from other foreign countries would love
to sit down with a Beyonce and people
would love to sit down with Beyonce I
don't know that she quite qualifies on
the billionaire list but maybe she's on
her way
Hova beyonce total dollar amount when
they put them together as the power
couple maybe that crack civilian yeah I
do think collectively you know people
running for president might you know be
able to collectively raise a billion
dollars so what's the difference I think
the sad part about if you have a
moderately enlightened billionaire I
think the very enlightened billionaires
are the ones are like forget politics I
don't well but isn't that the truth like
you were really forget about how much
money you have but if you were really an
enlightened person would you ever want
to run for political office marianne
williamson is running and she's a very
enlightened person I don't even know who
she is so she must be very unlikely she
speaks a lot about love and she's more
of a like a spiritual leader but she's
running for some seat somewhere right
now so but like Al Franken kind of did
that he cracked it open because it made
the media pay attention to him so I
think it's less about the money and more
about can you get new life into politics
yeah is it just a sad state of American
politics though that we might need a
billionaire to actually get money out I
yeah I don't think so I think the sadder
thing is if you are this moderately
enlightened billionaire who is going to
try and run you're not going to win the
presidency that is a fact I mean I just
don't see it happening
even if Oprah throws or her you know hat
in the ring yeah I think what that
accomplishes is what Nader accomplished
and what Perot accomplished which means
the person who's actually closest to you
on the political spectrum loses because
of you yeah so I just think the third
party system Al Gore right you know
George Bush like that is those are
things that arguably lost the election
any other decisions could have been made
but largely you know lost the election
for the person who was closing on the
political spectrum to the billionaire
who ran yeah or the large third party
doesn't have your vote
within a party I think that helps with
the picnic party like make it fun
I mean whoever the billionaire is it's
going to be a great party yeah they're
so serious all the time and all that but
the picnic party is pleasant maybe
champagne yeah something like those like
$5,000 a plate dinners like the
billionaire puts $5,000 on your plate
that's pretty good yeah hate that I'm
still getting email from the Obama
campaign
oh yeah asking me for money I don't that
I don't understand I'm trying to pay my
healthcare yeah well they have to usher
in the 2014 candidates that he likes to
it you say right but that's the problem
it's just a never-ending cycle but isn't
also part problem here is that we have
this like thing where now people are
really hating rich people rightly or
wrongly so the idea of a billionaire
self-funded candidate Michael Bloomberg
suddenly ran for president wouldn't the
populace would hate that right also the
Republicans site doesn't need that
because the Republican side there a lot
of the money comes from corporate
interests anyway so like the business
minded person running on the Republican
side that's not new that's not getting
the the corporate money like two percent
to forty eight percent or something like
I don't know the corporate money is one
thing but I think these moderately
enlightened candidates that Mader's
mentioning are all for a lot in a large
part like big democratically than what
they what I think he means by
enlightened is is the person for whose
money they put into politics isn't
expecting money to come directly back to
their cause or company that's what he
means right but there's other people who
are just like you know I'm gonna give
you money for my you know shoelace
making corporation so we can have my
kind of shoelace go to like every school
kid in Atlanta see I think it's a good
idea to start the conversation about it
I'm not necessarily I don't know if I
agree with the title MERP I think that's
a very proud mater moderately rich brand
or that picnic yeah that would have made
more sense
all right so last thought on this can we
ever get the money out I mean we do
something about this every week
we've been doing the show but the root
of this is just the ridiculous amount of
money in politics and you know I've now
presented this question three times but
the idea even how silly it is that you
need a billionaire to come in so that
the money could get out is there any
chance that the system will ever change
no no no I do I actually think this is
elevating the conversation so maybe
because democracy doesn't work right now
yeah I just bring us home if the
politician runs who is not for sale
there's someone on the other side who is
and it will kind of activate people to
over fun you know you get one
billionaire running against you know 25
billionaires giving to the other side
it's it's tough I'm gonna I think our
candidate is gonna be from New Mexico
and Happiness there actually